This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam and I'm Neil.
In this 6 Minute English, we're celebrating the life of one of modern South Africa's founding
fathers, the icon and Nobel laureate at Bishop Desmond Tutsu. Archbishop Tutsu was one of the
leaders of the non-violent movement to end the system of racial segregation known as apartheid.
apartheid was enforced against the black population of South Africa by the white minority
government from 1948 until 1991. It's impossible to imagine South Africa's difficult journey to
freedom without Archbishop Desmond Tutsu. While other anti-apartheid leaders, like his close friend
Nelson Mandela, were imprisoned or even killed, Archbishop Tutsu was there at every step of the
struggle. The rebellious priest speaking out against the injustices of apartheid. Archbishop Tutsu
was a hero of the 20th century. He died in December 2021 and was laid to rest in Cape Town in a state
funeral on New Year's Day. In this programme, we'll hear about some important moments from his life
and, as usual, learn some related vocabulary as well. But first, I have a question for you, Neil.
Nelson Mandela was sometimes affectionately called by his clan's name, Mediba. But do you know what
nickname Archbishop Desmond Tutsu was given? Was it A, the Des, B, the Bish, or C, the Arch?
I don't know, but I'll guess his nickname was C, the Arch.
Okay, Neil. We'll find out if that's the correct answer at the end of the programme.
Desmond and Pilo Tutsu was born in 1931 in the town of Clirksdorp in Northern South Africa.
In this 2014 interview with BBC World Service programme Outlook, he looks back on some of his
earliest childhood memories. I had a very happy childhood. I'm a boy,
child between two girls. My sister sometimes thought that our mother
rather spoiled me, pampered me. My mother was not educated much, but she had an incredible
loving for people and was very generous. Part of my own unhappiness was
precisely that anyone could want to take advantage of such a gracious, gentle, generous person.
As a child, Desmond Tutsu's mother would pamper him, give him special treatment and make him
feel special by doing nice things for him. He also says his mother spoiled him, let him do or have
whatever he wanted. Spoiling a child usually has a bad effect on their character as they grow up,
but this doesn't seem to be true for Desmond Tutsu. What upset the young Desmond was how his mother
was treated by some white South Africans who would take advantage of her, treat her unfairly
for their own benefit. In 1955, Desmond Tutsu married his wife, Leah. They had children and the
family moved to London for a time before returning to South Africa when Desmond was made Dean of
Johannesburg. He knew that returning to a racially segregated South Africa would be difficult for
his family. In this interview with BBC World Service Programme Outlook, Archbishop Tutsu remembers
one terrifying incident involving his wife, Leah, who had gone to the Johannesburg traffic
department to renew a car license. The handcuffs here, and they walked with him in the street,
often she was paraded, and then when the court case was heard, my wife was acquitted,
but they had done what they wanted to do, which was to humiliate her and in the process hit at me.
I have to say that I found those actions near unforgivable because I was the one who
was out in the forefront, although Leah, she's a toughie.
Police officers arrested and handcuffed Leah to humiliate her, make a feel ashamed and stupid.
When she went to court, Leah was acquitted, declared not guilty of committing a crime,
but the police continued to harass her even though his wife was in his own words a toughie,
someone who is tough and determined. Archbishop Tutsu describes the event as
near unforgivable, but in fact he did forgive the white police officers, and in 1991,
at the end of a part-ide, he started the Truth and Reconciliation Commission,
as a way of healing divisions between black and white communities.
What an inspirational life, but we still don't know what his nickname was, Sam.
Right, in my question, I asked Neil what Archbishop Desmond Tutsu's nickname was?
I guessed it was the arch.
Which was the correct answer.
Affectionately known as the arch, Desmond Tutsu will be remembered as a man of peace and forgiveness.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned in this program, starting with Pampa.
To give someone special treatment.
If you spoil a child, you let them do whatever they want, but be careful,
because they might take advantage of you, treat you badly for their own benefit.
To humiliate someone means to make them feel ashamed or stupid.
If you are acquitted of a crime, it is judged that you are not guilty.
And finally, a toughie is a slang word to describe someone like Archbishop Desmond Tutsu or his wife,
Leah, who is tough and determined.
Once again, our six minutes are up.
Goodbye for now.
Bye.